yo what's up my name is brandon perea
hey i'm stephen young what's up i'm kiki
palmer hey i'm daniel kaluya and we're
here for buzzfeed quiz to find out if we
would survive a jordan peel movie
all right first things first which
horror movie character trope do you
identify with the most the one who's
easily scared the one always falling the
one who questions everything the
misunderstood loner the one who never
takes things seriously
kiki which one are you so i'm a cross
between the one who questions everything
and the one who never takes things
seriously okay so i think for this i'm
going to go with the one who questions
everything because i need the
information
oh so kikis decide not to be honest
mine is also a cross between the one who
questions everything the misunderstood
loner maybe yeah maybe
okay but if since you took that one i'll
take the longer one all right okay
surprisingly since i do a lot of random
stuff that's very active like roller
skating breakdancing stuff i always fall
when i get scared like when i'm in a
haunted house i just dropped to my knees
that's surprising you seem so balanced
it's just weird if someone just i just i
just dropped that's just the first
instinct just go down
weird
yo i'm bow legged like a mom
which one did you choose i'm the one i'm
the one who questions everything wait is
that a man banging on your window
yelling trick-or-treat but it's july
what do you do first a pick out the
window to see who it is
b immediately lock the doors and windows
see check the surveillance video d let
your guard dog outside to scare them e
not a damn thing i'm going to wait it
out nf huh what makes you think i'm even
home i'm
i'm home i'm home yeah i'm home today i
think what makes you even think i'm home
because i'm really not home
i'm outside
i'm outside
probably i'm probably home peek out the
window see who it is that seems like the
logical next step and i'm a logical guy
good on you i'm immediately locking my
doors and windows i do not want to see
who it is ah he's made it inside what's
your next move call 9-1-1 find a hiding
spot scream attempt to run out the door
text your group chat your secret code
word go live to let your followers know
about the ordeal we'll go live
now who would go live i'm definitely
calling 9-1-1 immediately
i go straight to it i'm going for the
risk i'm going to run out the door i can
i can make it i wouldn't call 9-1-1
because i wouldn't want him to know i'm
inside but he can't tell how are you
going to know you you hear me
come on you can call me yourself i'm
talking about god
why are you saying
i'll just open the club yeah basically
oh kill him he's upstairs oh i'm cool
now you know what's the horror movie
honey i'm whispering and then they catch
that i got great control these these
options seem limited
i'm gonna say
it's not how i feel but the close ones
find a hiding spot damn you basically
what if joseph
he made it inside what's your next move
i'm calling that i'm calling 9-1-1 all
right oh no you hear him coming closer
so you decide to grab a weapon which one
are you choosing there's a fire
extinguisher a lamp a candelabra an
umbrella a pen or a vase i'm about to
whoop they ass with a fire extinguisher
that's the heaviest thing yes that's
true and it's durable too it's not going
to break it blink you know what i mean
yeah but candelabra is so
refined
yeah daniel where's the candelabra it's
a whole candle holder hey hey
it's a little teeny but it can't be
spiky some of that yeah yeah yeah and
it's like made of metal right yes i
think it it's about this could crack
somebody's head yeah shatter it i like a
refined smashing i'm gonna go with
candelabra nice nice nice i think it's
about fire extinguisher i just don't
know if i'll have like a great impact or
whatever i mean i'm like where would i
hit him right but you also got to spray
sprays in the face and then
i want to rescind my
you can you can
go back oh yeah no i don't think i can
oh i can oh
i've had a lot of buzz queens
buzzfeed was created
i hope that becomes a meme
next and every version of this nursery
rhyme begins to play now this is getting
weird row row row your boat twinkle
twinkle little star itsy bitsy spider
pop goes the weasel london bridge is
falling down and jack and jill which is
the creepiest one creepiest to us izzy
the pop goes the weasel a road where i
roll your boat pop goes louise is a
little too on the nose so i'm gonna go
row row your boat gently down the stream
that's scary
to get out of there if you sing it like
that it's not i think it's creepy you
know yeah but that's how it's got to be
song i would like them to sing
like the ice cream
i feel like if someone sings any other
song apart
i can beat them up
[Laughter]
lastly it looks like the killer finally
caught up to you but he'll only let you
go if you phone a friend to solve a
trivia question oh my god who are you
calling so we got tiffany haddish
lakeith stanfield keanu reeves lupita
nyong'o elizabeth moss and yaya abdul
mateen ii man for me it's between keanu
and la keith i feel like they both know
a lot for some reason
also i feel like even if the keith
didn't know the answer
he would figure out a way to like be
likable and it come help you yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah like he like he'd be like
where are you
he had a good weapon on it yeah
he'd have the candelabra yeah
i feel like tiffany would entertain the
killer a bit with some funny jokes and
tiffany has will be like yo hey how you
doing and then they'll be like so caught
off guard then that'll get me an
opportunity to get out of there
[Music]
you survived hey all right
what's it say okay in the famous words
of destiny's child you're a survivor
you're not going to give up and that's
exactly what happened you can
immediately sense when vibes are off so
you can have no problem taking
calculated wrists and moving swiftly and
it has a gift of my guy winston jute
saying we can get we can get crazy get
crazy
yeah yeah yeah i mean i got the same
exact thing me too i survived too yeah i
surprised let's get crazy we beat the
quiz we're survivors we're surviving uh
jordan peel movie so happy that they
chose the one character that died in the
jungle
[Laughter]
yes
hey buzzfeed i got ya
that was fun it's good that's good
appreciate that thank you
thanks for watching
and make sure you guys check out nope in
theaters july 22nd
[Music]
[Music]
you